بحث عن جرعه امل تتكبد اسر يمنيه عديده
مشقه سفر ساعات طويله ومضنيه عبر ما تيسر
من طرقات تعبر محافظه عده للوصول الى هذا
المركز الخاص بعلاج مرضى السرطان في تعز
صرخات الاطفال المرضى تملا المكان محاولات
تخفيف الامهم تصطدم بحاجز نقص الامكانيات
والادويه في ظل الاستمرار الحصار الذي
تفرضه ميليشيه الحوثي منذ اكثر من سبع
سنوات
اكثر الايام نشتري علاقت من الخارج
وبتكالف كبيره
نعالجه هنا بالمركز اا
اه بعيد علينا الطريق بسبب اغلقت المنافذ
الصور وتتحدث عن نفسها المركز يستقبل 200
حاله يوميا في المتوسط اطفال وشباب وشيوخ
ياتون من عده محافظات مجاوره لتعز عبر طرق
وعائره المعاناه مضاعفه بين بعد المسافه
وقصر ذات اليد ونقص المستلزمات الطبيه
من الحديده حتى بالاماكن الاخرى بعيده عن
همم محافظه
الطرق الا ان هناك
يصلون الينا وبمشقه وهناك وناس يغلقون على
انفسهم ابواب بيوتهم لعدم قدرتهم على
الوصول الى مركز الامل
عدد من اصيب بالسرطان عام 2015 كان 15
الفا لكنه بلغ 30,000 عام 2022 في مختلف
المحافظات وفق احصاءات المؤسسه الوطنيه
لمكافحه السرطان في اليمن وفي انتظار فك
الحصار تستمر المعاناه والامل ايضا لعوده
البسمه الى وجوه هؤلاء الاطفال بلال
البوجداني العربيه